حدث تاريخي في سوق السيارات شهدته المانيا
وهو ان مبيعات السيارات الكهربائيه
الجديده تجاوزت للمره الاولى مبيعات
السيارات التقليديه في شهر ديسمبر الماضي
هذا جزء من تحول كبير يحصل عالميا اذوا
للمره الاولى فاتت سيارات الكهربائيه تشكل
واحده من كل 10 سيارات جديده تباع حول
العالم هذا نتيجه لنمو الهاء اللي مبيعات
السيارات الكهربائيه بنسبه 68% في 20 22
22 لتصيله الى سبعه ملايين و800,000 سياره
وفقا للامسي
دوت كوم فما هي الاسواق الاكبر للسيارات
الكهربائيه الصين تقود الطفره استضافت
مبيعات تقريبا من مليونين و700,000 سياره
كهربائيه في 20 21 الى خمسه ملايين في 20
22 تخيل انا واحده من كل اربع سيارات
الصين العام الماضي كانت سياره كهربائيه
اوروبا تاتي في المرتبه الثانيه بنحو
مليون ونصف المليون سياره كهربائيه جديده
في 20 22 ومن ثم الولايات المتحده بنحو
807000 سياره السيارات الكهربائيه شكلت
11% من اجمالي مبيعات السيارات في اوروبا
و19% من اجماليات في الصين مقابل 5.8 فقط
في الولايات المتحده هذا التحول ونلاحظه
ايضا لدى الصانعين ففي المانيا اكبر سوق
للسيارات في اوروبا استحواذ السيارات
الكهربائيه على 25% من انتاج السيارات
الجديده العام المصري
قوي جدا بي ام دبليو
مبيعات الا انا مبيعات السيارات
الكهربائيه لديها قفزه في اكثر من الضرس
هل تفكر جديا بان تكون سيارتك التاليه
كهربائيه